non mais vous ne pouvez pas demander non
plus alain juppé se rouler sous la table
veut dire oh bah on va pas aller jusque
là n'ont ni 7 à 9 des taxes et le fait
de venir s'afficher avec françois fillon
qu'est ce que vous voulez voilà s'il
savait pas fait et vous auriez dit mais
où est ce qu est la jupe et il le fait
il ya oui mais bon voilà
non non ils sont rassemblés toute la
famille toute la famille est rassemblée
pour faire gagner notre candidat parce
que c'est important
la france est un aiguillage historique
et elle est en train de décrocher par
rapport aux pays européens dans un monde
qui est dangereux le terrorisme mais en
même temps ces empires ces vieux empire
qui sont en train de se reconstituer
monsieur erdogan
l'ancien empire ottoman et bien d'autres
donc le monde est dangereux et il faut
un homme qui a une stature et seul
françois fillon on le voit bien dans
cette campagne a une stature
présidentielle
nadège ah ouais je voulais revenir sur
les chiffres des sondages j'ai bien
entendu monsieur fillon qui nous a redit
quand je dis nous c'est dire les
journalistes illzach dit l'autre jour
vous vous êtes obsédé par les sondages
de toute façon oui ils sont tous faux
c'est pas vrai ce qu'ils racontent bah
oui mais enfin quand même on est bien
obligé un petit peu de les regarder et
c'est vrai qu'il a en permanence trois à
quatre points de moins que monsieur
maquereau ou que madame le pen donc un
deuxième tour sanaa ça s'annonce quand
même difficile vous y croyez c'est
normal sinon feriez pas de politiques si
vous ne croyez pas voire même peu
l'impression comme d'auto persuasion
comment il va faire pour monter de 4.4
jouent alors on va y aller chercher les
électeurs c'est la question pendant la
primaire il a monté de beaucoup plus en
très peu de temps vous le savez
parfaitement donc les sondages ne sont
pas les suffrages
et j'observe que depuis quelques jours
et loppsi y gagne beaucoup depuis le
début du mois d'avril
louis remonte dans les sondages il a
gagné deux points quand madame madame le
pen en perdait 2,5 comme monsieur
maquereau en perdez deux on voit bien
qu'il ya une dynamique de son côté kate
une dynamique positive
tout simplement parce qu une élection
c'est une comparaison et kobudo bout les
français comparent françois fillon son
projet qui est un vrai projet